can you've made a beautiful film I'm
wondering for those who want to see it
but are afraid of how it'll affect them
what's your message to them what's your
advice to them maybe they feel
passionate about the topics that are
covered whether it's gun control mental
illness
grief community but they're afraid to
have to go there what's your answer
right we've had that a lot that people
here at your the film is called Newtown
and maybe they have a fears about seeing
it but we've found in audiences that
people will generally have walked away
with a tremendous feeling of certainly a
lot of emotion but a lot of uplift and
hope in watching these this community
and these some of these parents who've
really just displayed remarkable
strength and resilience in moving
through the unthinkable and you know
more and more I feel that the the film
offers a lot of different things for a
lot of different people depending what
you're coming into it with because it's
in many ways as much about collective
grief and resilience as it is about the
underlying issues of what a community
looks like in the wake of this kind of
guy
gun violence even years out but I think
the film more than anything has given a
lot of people who see it a sense of
purpose around something that they that
so many Americans I think feeling more
and more passionate about changing I
believe you said that the film or the
opportunity to be part of the film came
to you almost by accident that you just
happen to be in a certain part of the
East Coast and met the right people yeah
not not exactly there was some
colleagues that I'd worked with in the
past some people from from something
called transform films and I had
explored a project with them in the
Middle East right before Arab Spring and
that didn't come to fruition because
because Arab Spring made it their
prohibited us from from developing it
and they called me a couple weeks after
the tragedy and said we have some
we have some contacts in Newtown and are
very much interested in exploring
something short form and maybe something
longer form would you consider going up
and exploring that with us and I was
very reluctant and just thought you know
there's so many news cameras and I'm not
from the news and I felt icky I felt
like these people deserve their privacy
and the whole idea of in some way
competing with other cameras just sort
of turned my stomach so I was a
completely reluctant filmmaker going up
there and a little by little I just
became more and more immersed in more
than gee I want to make a film about gun
violence in Newtown is the place to do
it I just was feeling the enormity of
the trauma first through developing a
relationship with the local priest
father Bob and being so struck with his
burden well I don't want to say burden
and that's not what he would say but
from my perspective you know just these
good small-town folks living their lives
being thrust into these roles whether it
be the priest shouldering all this grief
or the emergency room doctor who's
tasked with receiving the children of
his own colleagues in the ER room that
day or whether it be the teacher who's
tasked with just for you know protecting
her twenty students I was just struck
with these different sub communities and
their their journeys as well as of
course the families who lost everything
right now you just have to address this
and I'm hoping that you can speak to our
viewers for those who then there's a
strong community of people that think
that Sandy Hook was a hoax and that this
was staged and that the maybe people in
the film were acting how can you
you squash that how can you tell us that
that is not true because I know it's an
insult for me to ask especially if
there's family members grieving and it
is an insulting question but I just have
to cover it yes it's um shocking and
disturbing to me as a documentarian I
was aware of it and had to make a
decision you know not a difficult
decision not to give that any lip
service whatsoever it's no different to
me than Holocaust deniers and a whole
number of really you know crazy
conspiracy theories but I mean what I
can do is mirror one of my subjects mark
Barden who lost his seven-year-old son
Daniel just recently for the first time
somewhere we encountered somebody who
didn't was not a truther as they called
themselves he but he revealed that his
son was one of those people and revealed
that to mark and I thought mark was just
going to go crazy on him and he just in
the most dignified way said don't I wish
that were true
don't I wish this never happened them
that I had my my my Daniel back you know
what I can say is that there's twenty
eight thousand people in Newtown I'm
pretty sure all of whom were traumatized
in one way or another by this who and
the ripple effects throughout
Connecticut of everyone who knew
somebody who went to those funerals and
it's just really it's not even something
I can comment on it's so it's so
disturbing well lastly and then we'll
move on from that why do you think the
the just I mean the vitriolic comments
that are on these videos and it just
knowing that there are families that
have been affected by this people whose
lives will never ever be the same
why why such a strong argument that this
never happened why do you think these
people feel so right to
make these arguments you know I guess
it's the subject of another documentary
honestly I have in my mind thought what
what is that the root of these kinds of
conspiracies are a majority these people
mentally unbalanced do they then get
followers that but I don't think it's
different than Holocaust deniers and any
other number of you know 9/11 conspiracy
theorists it's you know it's do I think
it could be as simple as you know an
article I read the other day that said
perhaps they're just in you know want to
be in such denial that's such a horrific
thing could happen yeah that that this
could could actually happen I mean
another small just detail thing is from
what I understand a lot of the parents
fought hard to keep certain crime-scene
photos out of public domain which I'm
very happy that they won that fight in
Connecticut so that they wouldn't have
to if they didn't want to see those
images out on the Internet and so I
think that you know for those kind of
people may have fed some of this that
they couldn't access you know maybe the
same kind of evidence if you will you
know and the same thing happen with
Osama bin Laden I mean it's happened
with so many things of like show us the
proof so anyway I it's not something I
like to spend a lot of time thinking
about because it's just so awful
understood ok moving on your decision
not to focus heavily on the shooter and
his family I know you touch on it
briefly which I feel is just enough but
what was your decision-making behind
that it's something my producing partner
Maria and I talked a lot about along
with our editor Gabe you know we just it
was two things it didn't feel like it
was the movie we were making to really
delve into
and his issues and how he came to be it
felt like the subject of another and a
subject that gets a fair amount of focus
the shooters in general it felt for me
as a filmmaker that that was not the
truth of what you know if I was trying
to stay true to the point of view of the
psychology collective psychology of the
town from what I could take in there
wasn't a lot of bandwidth of examining
that they were they had their heads and
hearts full with all kinds of other
processes of of grieving and and so that
that felt truthful in terms of the film
that I was making and thirdly you know
we became a widow
well Maria had had been aware for some
time but there is a growing movement
among victim communities called no
notoriety asking the press not to name
the shooters with with the idea that
there can be copycats and just to not to
not give more attention you know and and
to reciprocally give more attention to
the the lives that are left in the wake
the individuals that you spoke to in the
film the parents some of the first
responders they seemed so ready to speak
were they that trusting when you first
met them because that's one you know
access is one thing a documentary
filmmaker faces and then the trust of
the subjects people can do whatever to
sort of mask what they're really feeling
but these people just seem so trusting
of you was that immediate or did that
take time it was case by case I think
that with some of the what we called
testimonial interviews against black
some of them more first time I almost
always had a number of off-camera
conversations that really delved into me
expressing the the film and the intent
of what we were trying to do in a story
of aftermath it was a little bit of
unlearning of this is different maybe
than short form news for those who
didn't know the process of long-form
documentary filmmaking that this was
more there wasn't a
appointed agenda it was what do you
think why why do you think this is
important because by virtue of them
saying I think I might be interested to
participate meant that they either had a
purpose a a cathartic that they thought
it could be cathartic so in some times I
did witness that there was a kind of
cathartic therapeutic role in cynics
sometimes we would leave the room
completely so it felt almost more
therapeutic confessional and I think
that you know with the case of the
parents that wasn't true it was very
different that took a long time of
building trust and one thing I observed
and I certainly am NOT an expert on
trauma but something I observed is that
when this happens something so horrible
to any of us you you you live with a
sense of control all control has been
taken away from you so what I tried to
do was lend a lot of flexibility and
choices so it was never sort of let's do
this and this is how it's going to go it
was sort of very fluid what do you think
what would you like to explore so with
you lead me this is collaborative
what is the story that we should tell
and why why is it important and then it
became really interesting as we talk
about these ripple effects and these
other layers of the onion we you know in
the community whose story is it to tell
because that was really at the crux of a
lot of the friction and healing I think
in the community was you know whose
grief counts and whose story is it to
say and what what I was interested in
doing was making a composite of
redefining victim as entire community
this is what happens it's an entire
community and yes these few families
that that participated we're willing to
participate we're at the epicenter and
everyone's sort of revolving around them
of having lost their loved ones but
everybody suffered an enormous
life-changing
trauma and loss I know you've had a few
festival screenings I mean that the film
is going to be released to the general
public I believe November 2nd and then
we'll have a town hall
well we released last week in New York
City theatrically tomorrow night in the
Monica here in LA and and then we're
doing something unusual and
unprecedented for a documentary
following those we will open on nearly
500 at the moment 500 big box screens
across the country on November 2nd with
fathom events in a with a live Town Hall
conversation a national conversation
that really tries to open up dialogue
and have these different constituents of
the community come together so that we
take it out of the weedy politicize this
we take it out of that horribly
polarized place and talk about it in the
humanitarian space that it needs to be
so if those who are not within the
community not within even Connecticut
what have been some of the most powerful
statements said to you after seeing the
film maybe at a festival screening gosh
so many everything from I'm an hour nra
guy in Utah and I got to tell you that
this film has reached me and made me
rethink things you're gonna reach guys
like me someone said that somebody said
that to me I've had people come up and
say you know I've lost a child and
nothing speaks to the process of grief
in quite this way were a society that
you know it has a tough time dealing
with grief and I've had young people
we've had so many Highschool late high
school and college students say this
film has moved me in a way that I want
to dedicate you know the rest of my
college years to fighting for this cause
so I think we've we've had reactions
that are both within the the choir so to
speak but I don't even like to say that
because 90% of the country agrees that
status quo that inaction is not an
option anymore
and so it's um it's a matter of just
getting people to put this on the table
to not be you know not to not be put it
in this polarized political space when
we talk about it and to really
acknowledge that it's a public health
crisis talking about let's talk about
finding distribution for the film how
was that especially knowing that it's a
powerful film but that people may be
scared in that it will affect them so
deeply because it's it's you know a
beautiful portrayal in some sense but
it's also very moving and that you feel
helpless at times Maria and I feel
blessed because we have we were able to
secure a broadcast pretty early on in
the process with our partners itvs so it
will air on independent lens in early
2017 it'll be available digitally on
Netflix prior to that and you know the
theatrical rollout you know we really
encourage people to come see it as a
group because the film is really about
community and what we're going to do as
a larger family of of community to to
not only have the backs of people who've
suffered this but to sort of break out
of our denial and desensitization that
this could be any one of us at any time
in any town it knows no boundaries
it is epidemic and so to that end were
we are thrilled and really are
encouraging people to come on November
2nd almost as we see the film as a
movement at this point from the reaction
we've had since Sundance and we've had
the opportunity to screen at the White
House and at Congress so we've we've
we've done a lot with it in in just
these past months let's talk about
making a feature versus on making a
short I know you've done two prior
feature films one about religion and
politics in a small town I believe and
the other one about chronic fatigue
syndrome yeah the first one wasn't so
much about religion it was um it was
about changing demographics and
immigrant immigrant integration in
small-town America
Sheldon welcome to show yes and that was
in rural Tennessee and started on the
eve of the election of President Obama
and and the other one was a more
personal my first documentary about
mysterious illness chronic fatigue
syndrome and millions of people trying
to to figure out what it what it is and
that journey so how is it because I know
you have many shorts also right and
you're in your portfolio so how is that
making a feature film versus a short I
realized that's going to differ with the
subject matter
yeah access but but in terms of the
amount of energy and sure output
I love interspersing them I mean I
probably I'm working on a short now that
is related to the same issue or a number
of shorts but I like you know I think
it's tough after a three to four year
halt to just you know I guess it's like
having kids or something where you know
you know how quickly do you sort of
delve into it again sometimes you wait
and sometimes you don't but I love the
genre of short film even there are more
platforms now for it and I I think you
know efficient filmic filmmaking can I
think a lot of documentaries are too
long nowadays and in some ways and and
not all need to be feature like length
films so I I love the I just love the
genre as much as I love short stories
versus novels so it's it's something I
love working with